Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie
Ryan Reynolds just posted a whole bunch of Deadpool
3 parody scenes in honor
of his big Deadpool leaks post
you probably saw on your feeds this morning.
And part of it was referencing the original Deadpool
test footage leaking back in 2014.
Think about how long it's been said
that it seems like it's been forever.
Ryan Reynolds made a couple posts about everything
that's been going on with him filming Deadpool 3.
This video is mostly going to be about the pictures,
the scenes that he posted this morning.
As of me posting this video.
some people will be watching this video
like three years being like,
was he talking about Ryan Reynolds
as has posted anything in like a couple of weeks?
but a lot of this goes back to the origins of the very
first Deadpool movie
that he's referencing in all of his posts.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
I will do more Deadpool
three videos as we learn more about the movie.
We'll get an official trailer pretty soon to.
But if you didn't see it early this morning,
Ryan Reynolds posted.
Deadpool began with a leak.
So I'm joining in,
but please don't overuse the phrase Deadpool leaks
because it might screw up Search results.
If anyone is actually looking for Deadpool
leaks or Deadpool spoilers, or perhaps Deadpool scoops
all very tongue in cheek like Yes,
please post about this as much as possible.
With the pictures
that Ryan Reynolds posted of parody leaks and scoops.
when he says Deadpool began with the leak, he's
talking about
the very original Deadpool movie back in 2016 beginning
because of a leak.
if you don't remember the original timeline
on that first movie, he's
actually posted a bunch of jokes and parody videos
about what happened with that.
Started as an idea.
What if we made a Deadpool movie?
There was only a few of us back then, and looking back
we had no idea how big it would become.
So innocent.
And yet the momentum that had started,
it was not really what we had in mind,
though.
That didn't help things.
It was more of a hell no.
To be honest. I mean, we eventually stopped asking.
We have no idea how that happened.
But I promise you, I'm looking into it.
But once the movie got greenlit,
I went on a massive coke bender.
So 2016, this little hazy for me.
They tell me the movie did well, though
ten years into it,
phase one has exceeded our wildest expectations.
Zero.
If you told me back then that one movie would spawn
an expansive two movie universe,
I have said that you were crazy.
But here we are with actual actors.
A moderate special effects budget
and several low level X-Men.
None of the big ones, though.
We've got to save something for phase two.
He doesn't totally get into the original timeline
for the movie.
Like he skips over some of the early parts of them
developing a Deadpool movie.
It actually started back in the year 2000.
It artisan entertainment.
They acquired the rights to produce a Deadpool movie
as a result of Marvel's
bankruptcy in the nineties,
where they sold off most of their big characters.
Ryan Reynolds didn't actually start working
on developing a Deadpool movie
until 2004 with David Goyer,
who he'd worked with on the Blade movies.
most people remember David Goyer
as the person who wrote the Blade movies.
He wrote Batman Begins, Some A Dark Knight, Some A Dark
Knight Rises, Man of Steel, Batman v Superman.
He was producer on the first Ghost Rider movie.
He's on a bunch of comic book movies.
one of the reasons why Ryan Reynolds
started to develop that original version
of the Deadpool movie back in 2004 was because he saw
that they were making fun of him inside the Deadpool
comic books like Deadpool
was making fun of Ryan Reynolds inside his comic books,
which he thought was pretty cool
they wound up having some rights issues with Fox
because Fox got the rights to all the X-Men characters.
And technically, legally, Deadpool
was considered an X-Men character
because he was inside the X-Men comic books.
They get really into the weeds
on who owns what character rights.
it's still a really big thing
with the Hulk movies right now.
Why Marvel has not done a solo Hulk movie since
they've been doing all the more modern Marvel movies.
Then in 2005, Fox expressed an interest
in making a Deadpool movie.
So Ryan Reynolds continued
working on the movie. Behind the scenes.
Then he had his cameo as Deadpool in Wolverine
Origins in 2009.
in the rest of the timeline
basically plays out the way that you see it.
In his parody video, they're talking about
the origin of the leaks for that first movie,
The studio that produced
the Deadpool test footage was hired in 2012.
They made that actual test footage that leaked out,
But at the time, back in 2012, Fox didn't like it,
so they just shelved the project and they just sat
there for a couple of years until Ryan Reynolds himself
leaked the test footage right before Comic-Con 2014,
and it blew up all over the Internet.
People probably remember
I even did a video about it on my channel back in 2014
that convinced Fox to actually greenlight
the first Deadpool movie and get it made.
So when Ryan Reynolds said
the first Deadpool movie started because of a leak,
that's the leak he's talking about.
he's also posted several other parody and joke videos
since then about discovering or uncovering
who actually leaked the original Deadpool test footage,
when in reality he was the person that did it himself
because at the time he was the only person
in the studio who had enough juice
if things went south, like if it went badly,
he wouldn't get fired
the same way that other people would get fired
or retaliated against or sued.
So this past year when parts of a scene from Deadpool
three started working their way around big websites,
Ryan Reynolds posted about it eventually
just explaining why so much of the movie was being done
practically instead of full CG,
to give it much more of an authentic look and feel.
And he's right. Like they are right to do it that way.
he politely asked people not to freak out too much in
the movie would be amazing.
Like, everybody chill a little bit.
Movie is going to be awesome.
kind of like the version of Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness that you probably imagine
we were going to get
instead of the one that we actually got.
Like bring all the X-Men back.
X-Men, No Way Home, Spider-Man, No Way Home style.
For all those classic X-Men actors.
and to commemorate his post,
like the original Deadpool leaks,
he dropped a bunch of his own leaks, parodies,
making fun of it all.
This one is Deadpool and Wolverine
behind the scenes with their stunt doubles
talking to the Predator
like a joke about all the cameos in the movie.
Like who's in this movie?
What's the Predator doing on the Void Planet here
from the Loki series?
What's he going to be doing with all the characters,
one of the other jokes here, too,
if you didn't realize,
is that Fox owns the rights to the Predator movies,
which is why he's able to put the Predator in here.
Like, see,
we're doing all these Fox characters coming back.
that's why the Predator is in the movie.
if it wasn't clear, though,
the Predator is not actually in the movie, like
this is just a big joke that Ryan Reynolds is making.
some people probably saw this
and actually thought it was real.
Like what?
part of the idea with all the cameos,
like the X-Men characters coming back,
you see the 20th Century Fox logo wreckage
behind them in a lot of these scenes Ryan
Reynolds changed the title here from the 20th Century
Fox logo to the Quibi logo like R.I.P.
Quibi.
It also got pruned by the TVA,
something that nobody will miss
but in the actual movie
it is the 20th Century Fox logo.
is basically them battling it out with a bunch of other
X-Men characters from the original Bryan
Singer X-Men movies in front of the 20th Century
Fox logo on the Void planet from Loki,
which is meant to be a huge metaphor
for what's happening in real life with Kevin.
FYI, in the Marvel people getting rid
of all the old X-Men movies and recasting the actors
so that they can do new X-Men movies
with a new version of the team.
so the meta joke is that the old X-Men all got pruned.
20th Century Fox got pruned
because it got bought by Disney,
absorbed by Disney, basically
and they all got sent to the Void planet
where everything the TVA prunes gets sent,
where they're all surviving in a mad max like state.
This post-apocalyptic environment,
repurposing all of the other vehicles,
the weapons that get sent there by the TVA
from other Marvel movies and universes,
For example, in this other scene here
that Ryan Reynolds posted, the car behind
Wolverine is a version of Red School's
car from the first Captain America movie with Blasters.
That seem like they're from the first Avengers movie
they could be from one of the other X-Men movies do.
most of the stuff that's in all the scenes
that Ryan Reynolds has been posting are from the older
X-Men movies in some of the older MCU movies
with the exception
of the TVA characters from the Loki series,
which is more recent.
But like Ryan Reynolds.
Add the bag of cash here that he's holding.
Mickey Mouse cheering
them on is a big Disney joke like the joke being
that they're only coming back
because they're being paid so much money.
Bags and bags of money. Look at it. Everybody.
the other scene of Deadpool and Wolverine
fighting it out in front of the 20th Century
Fox sign has Steve Urkel from Family Matters
instead of the TVA agent.
There's the beats signed by Ryan
Reynolds, edited to poke fun at one of the assistance
in the movie, holding cue cards the wrong way,
Like hold it up.
Someone else even edited an older version of Loki
into one of the shots of Deadpool
fighting Wolverine earlier during this scene.
But this is like a really bad Photoshop,
so like it's clearly meant to be fake
as far as I know,
Loki is not inside this movie in any way.
Like currently.
This is taking place after the events of the Loki
Season two finale, so he's currently in the middle
of the multiverse holding everything together,
kind of like a custodian of the multiverse.
But if it wasn't clear, the reason Ryan
Reynolds is doing all this is just because it's a joke.
He's poking fun at all of this.
I think a lot of people
missed the sarcasm in his posts.
Just because Twitter
or X is where sarcasm kind of goes. The die.
so they're probably done filming
most of this outdoors stuff, like in plain view.
I think a lot of people lose sight of that like,
No, no, no, Like, this isn't the entire movie.
This is like one or 2 minutes of like a two
and a half hour movie at most.
we will get some more details about the actual movie,
and it'll probably be a couple months
before we see the first big trailer.
My assumption is they'll drop the first teaser trailer
at the Super Bowl in February.
if you remember the original Deadpool
movie came out around Valentine's Day,
which is that second week in February,
pretty close to when the Super Bowl happens.
even though they will drop traditional trailers
like you do for any old movie, any Marvel movie,
any comic book movie, any movie,
just in general, I'm hoping that they actually use
some energy from the marketing campaigns
on the first couple of Deadpool movies,
like, for instance, the marketing campaign
on that first Deadpool movie is still peak like
it is still one of the best movie marketing campaigns
from any kind of movie I've ever seen
and one of the beauties of situations
like that, too, is that you can actually market
the movie without revealing
what's actually going on in the movie.
Like a lot of the promos that Ryan Reynolds did
for that first Deadpool movie, don't tell you
anything about the actual plot of the film in
now that Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine is a big part of Deadpool three
he and Hugh Jackman both together
have done a bunch of promos in parody ads for stuff
that has nothing to do with actual comic book movies.
So they can actually do that together
in it'll be way, way better.
so I'm hoping that Hugh Jackman
also gets in on the fun, too.
He kind of did that with Ryan Reynolds
Post this morning, too, with him commenting on
some of his recent posts about the fake leaks
that he was dropping.
whatever a cool and super weird post
they wind up making whatever kind of weird promos
they might have dropping.
Of course, I'll do videos for it.
have any questions or any special requests
for Deadpool videos, while we're
waiting for them to draw out the actual trailer,
just let me know in the comments.
the next real big thing that I'll be doing
videos for will be for the
what if season two episodes at the end of December.
We should get some more trailers for that pretty soon.
And then after that we should get some trailers
for the X-Men 97 episodes.
but I don't think those episodes are supposed to drop
till at least March
maybe a little bit later than that.
But we should start seeing footage for that.
When we start seeing actual official footage
for Deadpool three everyone click here
for that other big Deadpool 3 teaser and click here
to learn about X-23 coming back.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!